Professor Amy
Hungerford:
I want to start my lecture
today looking back to that
handout I gave you--but didn't
give you a discussion of--a
couple of days ago,
from that essay Good Readers
and Good Writers that I
quoted at the very beginning of
class this term.
If you took the time to read
that, what you saw is Nabokov
meditating on how reader and
writers meet,
and so I just want to read to
you a little bit from that.
If you still have it,
you can get it out:
The real writer,
the fellow who sends planets
spinning and models a man asleep
and eagerly tampers with the
sleeper's rib,
that kind of author has no
given values at his disposal:
he must create them himself.
The art of writing is a very
futile business if it does not
imply first of all the art of
seeing the world as the
potentiality of fiction.
The material of this world may
be real enough (as far as
reality goes) but it does not
exist at all as an accepted
entirety: it is chaos,
and to this chaos the author
says "go!"
allowing the world to flicker
and to fuse.
It is now recombined in its
very atoms, not merely in its
visible and superficial parts.
The writer is the first man to
map it and to name the natural
objects it contains.
Those berries are edible.
That speckled creature that
bolted across my path might be
tamed.
That lake between those trees
will be called Lake Opal or,
more artistically,
Dishwater Lake.
That mist is a mountain--and
that mountain must be conquered.
Up a trackless slope climbs the
master artist,
and at the top,
on a windy ridge,
whom do you think he meets?
The panting and happy reader,
and there they spontaneously
embrace and are linked forever
if the book lasts forever.
So, this is Nabokov's beautiful
evocation of how writer and
reader meet at the summit of
this misty mountain of the
imagination.
But, I've been suggesting to
you over the course of the
lectures so far this term that
this is,
for many books,
a totally idealized sense of
how a reader encounters it.
And no book demonstrates that
in quite the same way on our
syllabus as Lolita
itself.
It's true that Black Boy
was censored,
even after it was published in
its abbreviated form.
In the '80s it was censored
from high school libraries,
but Lolita was censored
at the very start in a different
way, and completely.
If you read,
as I asked you to do,
the essay at the back,
On a Book Entitled Lolita,
you'll see,
as Nabokov describes,
he circulated it to American
publishers,
four of them,
and it was turned down by
everybody, finally published in
France by the Olympia Press
which had also published other
controversial books like
Naked Lunch and Lady
Chatterley's Lover.
Nabokov cannot meet his
reader on the misty mountain
because somebody has to agree to
publish this book first;
it has to exist in the world
before that reader can meet it.
And the very fact of
censorship--So,
the book was published by the
Olympia Press,
and then it was banned in
France and in Britain;
it was imported into the United
States, and several years later
an American publication was
made.
And it rocketed to the
bestseller list.
So, it was a very popular book
in the U.S., but it did have
this history of being banned in
Europe, and it was certainly
controversial here.
Therefore, the mark of
censorship is actually still on
this book.
The essay that you read was
produced at the behest of his
French publisher.
They wanted him to write
something that would make people
feel better about the book,
that would give some account of
its origin and give some defense
for its publication and its
content.
And so, we have it bound with
the book, always,
now.
And so, in a way,
you can say that,
although it's Nabokov's voice,
and it's adding to the novel
(nothing was taken away from the
novel in the way that half of
Black Boy was removed
before it was published),
it's still deformed in a
certain way, or influenced by
the history of that censorship.
Now, I think it's worth
thinking about what he says in
that essay.
And I'm especially interested
in this passage on 313 about the
genre fiction of pornography,
so this is 313,
if you'll turn to it:
In modern times the term
'pornography' connotes
mediocrity, commercialism,
and certain strict rules of
narration.
Obscenity must be mated with
banality because every kind of
aesthetic enjoyment has to be
entirely replaced by simple
sexual stimulation which demands
the traditional word for direct
action upon the patient.
Old, rigid rules must be
followed by the pornographer in
order to have his patient feel
the same security of
satisfaction as,
for example,
fans of detective stories feel,
stories where if you do not
watch out the real murderer may
turn out to be,
to the fans' disgust,
artistic originality.
Who, for instance,
would want a detective story
without a single dialogue in it?
Thus, in pornographic novels
action has to be limited to the
copulation of
clichés.
Artistic originality turns out
to be the murderer,
to the fans' disgust.
Artistic originality here is
likened to the murderer of
convention.
It's originality that destroys
convention, and here it's given
that frisson of being a
criminal too.
He's suggesting the criminality
of real artistic innovation,
and by doing that,
by using that language to
describe artistic originality,
he allies artistic originality
with the figure of Humbert.
So, there are multiple ways,
at multiple levels,
that Nabokov is defending his
work in this afterword.
For one thing,
he insults the publishers.
He suggests that they didn't
finish the manuscript because,
when his manuscript turned out
not to be pornographic genre
fiction,
they stopped reading,
'cause that's what they wanted,
and they said,
"This is terrible,"
put it down.
So, he insults the people who
turned down the book in the
United States;
he allies originality with
criminality, and he suggests
that it is the banal attention
to convention that is,
in fact, what needs to be
censored, what needs to be done
away with.
He also gives us,
if you notice,
his little secret map of
Lolita, or so it
seems as it's presented to us,
his secret map of the scenes
that delight him in his own
novel, and this is on 316:
I find it [Lolita]
to be a delightful presence now
that it quietly hangs about the
house like a summer day which
one knows to be bright behind
the haze.
[There he's playing with the
name Haze.]
And when I thus think of
Lolita,
I seem always to pick out for
special delectation such images
as Mr.
Taxovich, or that class list of
Ramsdale School,
or Charlotte saying
"waterproof,"
or Lolita in slow motion
advancing towards Humbert's
gifts, or the pictures
decorating the stylized garret
of Gaston Godin,
or the Kasbeam barber who cost
me a month of work,
or Lolita playing tennis,
or the hospital at Elphinstone,
or pale, pregnant,
beloved, irretrievable Dolly
Schiller dying in Gray Star,
the capital town of the book,
or the tinkling sounds of the
valley town coming up the
mountain trail on which I caught
the first known female of
Lycaeides sublivens--[my
Latin is bad]
Nabokov These are the
nerves of the novel.
These are the secret points,
the subliminal coordinates by
means of which the book is
plotted--although I realize very
clearly that these and other
scenes will be skimmed over and
not noticed,
or never even reached,
by those who begin reading the
book under the impression that
it is something along the lines
of Memoirs of a Woman of
Pleasure.
He says these are the scenes,
and I want you to keep those
scenes in mind.
Some of them we've already
talked about.
Andrew talked about the class
list and gave you some ways of
understanding those pictures in
Gaston Godin's apartment.
So, we've talked about those.
Today, I'm going to pick up on
some of those other scenes that
he mentions as his secret points
of delight in the novel.
What kind of novel do we see if
we attend to those scenes?
So, what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to take that
essay--the product of
censorship,
the response to censorship--and
I'm going to use it to read back
into the novel.
And I want to work with you to
see what we can see,
if we use those scenes as our
points of reference.
And so, our task today will be
to think about that second road
trip in the novel--so,
this was your reading for
today--to begin at that second
road trip that Lolita initiates
and think about what happens to
the novel from there to the end.
Now, the most conspicuous
things that happen are an
increase in the violence of the
novel.
He hits her;
he pushes her;
he rapes her repeatedly.
We see more of those scenes in
the second half of the novel.
His style becomes more manic.
It gets even funnier.
There are many passages of
outright comedy in this second
half, especially the shooting of
Quilty,
which is a sort of parody of
the climax of a crime movie.
So there are all kinds of
flourishes in the style,
and Humbert presents himself as
more and more of a hapless
madman.
You can see it in his
perceptions.
You can see it in his language.
You can see it in the behavior
he reports, as when he vomits at
the resort in Colorado when he
thinks that Lolita has gone
away,
and then he sees her playing
with a dog, and he thinks,
"Oh, if only she would play
with me;
she's playing with a damn dog,"
and then he's sickened by this
idea.
You see more of that kind of
physical deterioration.
He drinks more.
So, he's getting very desperate.
Lolita, on the other hand,
becomes more calculating,
and it's this that I want to
focus in on today:
what becomes of Lolita in this
second part?
And I want to suggest,
if we turn to page 207 and the
beginning of that trip,
I want to suggest that in the
second half Lolita takes on the
role of the artist.
If you'll recall,
the two of them have a fight
over her participation in the
play because he suspects her of
deceiving him somehow:
either with boys,
or, somehow,
with someone associated with
the play.
He doesn't quite suspect the
truth yet, that she has met
Quilty through that play.
So, they have this big fight.
It's raining.
She rides her bicycle away into
the rain when the neighbor calls
to complain about their yelling
at each other.
So this is on 206,207:
"In front of the first
drugstore I saw with what melody
of relief Lolita's fair bicycle
waiting for her.
I pushed instead of pulling,
pulled, pushed,
pulled and entered."
Okay.
There he is struggling with the
door.
There is that physical comedy,
and I'll suggest to you that in
that sentence,
the pushing and pulling,
you're seeing part of Nabokov's
verbal play.
It's not just,
sort of, physical comedy
translated into prose,
but there are a host of other
moments in the novel where
pushing and pulling figure:
darkly in one of the rape
scenes (he pushes her in to a
room);
less darkly at the drugstore
(the soda jerk pulling on the
levers of the dispenser).
"Look out!"
Some ten paces away Lolita
through a glass at a telephone
booth, membranous god still with
us,
cupping the tube
confidentially,
hunched over it,
slit her eyes at me,
turned away with her treasure,
hurriedly hang up and walked
out with a flourish.
So, here now,
we move from Humbert's verbal
flourish, to Lolita's physical
one:
"Tried to reach you at
home," she said brightly.
"A great decision has been made.
But first, buy me a drink, Dad."
She watched the listless,
pale fountain girl put in the
ice, pour in the Coke,
add the cherry syrup,
and my heart was bursting with
love-ache: that childish wrist!
My lovely child!
"You have a lovely child,
Mr.
Humbert.
We always admire her as she
passes by."
Mr.
Pim watches Pippa suck the
concoction.
J'ai toujours admire la
supreme l'oeuvre ormonde du
sublime Dublinois.
And in the meantime the rain
had become a voluptuous
shower.
So, here is his verbal ecstasy
as he watches her:
"Look," she said as she
rode the bike beside me,
one foot scraping the darkly
glistening sidewalk.
"Look.
I've decided something.
I want to leave school.
I hate that school.
I hate the play.
I really do.
Never go back.
Find another.
Leave at once.
Go for a long trip again,
but this time we'll go wherever
I want, won't we?"
I nodded.
My Lolita.
'I choose;
c'est entendu?"
she said, wobbling a little
beside me.
Used French only when she was a
very good little girl.
"Okay, Entendu.
Now hop, hop,
hop, Lenore,
or you'll get soaked."
A storm of sobs was filling my
chest.
She bared her teeth and after
her adorable schoolgirl fashion
leaned forward,
and away she sped,
my bird.
Miss Lester's finely groomed
hand held the porch door open
for a wobbling old dog qui
prenait son temps. Lo was
waiting for me near the ghostly
birch tree.
"I'm drenched," she declared at
the top of her voice.
"Are you glad?
To hell with the play!
See what I mean?"
An invisible hag's claw slammed
down an upper floor window.
In our hallway,
ablaze with welcoming lights,
my Lolita peeled off her
sweater,
shook her gemmed hair,
stretched towards me two bare
arms, raised one knee.
"Carry me upstairs, please.
I feel sort of romantic
tonight."
She's seducing him in this
scene, so the flourish passes
from his prose.
It's not gone from his prose,
but in this scene,
very clearly,
it passes from his prose into
her acting.
And Humbert reflects that her
work in the play has trained her
into certain affectations.
Unfortunately for him,
he doesn't exactly spot this
one.
She, now, is using the
clichés of romance to
seduce him into following her
map for their second journey,
starting out on the second
journey by calling forth all his
mad love for her,
so that he will be,
in a sense, blinded by that and
not see her machinations.
You see it again on 209,
a little later in this scene.
His suspicion is aroused when a
car pulls up next to them as
they're heading out of town.
It's Edusa Gold driving up next
to them, and he's asking who was
it exactly that had been
impressed by Lolita's acting.
And Lolita takes him to mean,
who was the person in the car
next to them,
not who was the person that the
person in the car was referring
to.
"I was not referring to
her."
"Who, exactly,
concocted that play?"
"Oh, yes, of course.
Some old woman,
Claire something I guess.
There was quite a crowd of them
there."
"So she complimented you."
"Complimented, my eye.
She kissed me on my pure brow,"
and my darling emitted that new
yelp of merriment which,
perhaps in connection with her
theatrical mannerisms,
she had lately begun to
affect."
And I just want to skip down to
the bottom of that paragraph.
He gives her a kind of
warning--which I'm going to talk
about in a little while--but at
the very end he says,
"The tour of your thigh,
you know, should not exceed
seventeen-and-a-half inches."
He's warning her not to grow
up, essentially:
"'More might be fatal.'
I was kidding of course.
We are now setting out on a
long, happy journey.
I remember…."
And then, look at the paragraph
break there.
"I remember as a child…"
Now, this is not in quotes:
I remember as a child in
Europe gloating over a map of
North America that had
Appalachian mountains boldly
running from Alabama up to New
Brunswick,
so that the whole region they
spanned, Tennessee to Virginias,
Pennsylvania,
New York, Vermont,
New Hampshire and Maine,
appeared to my imagination as a
gigantic Switzerland or even
Tibet: all mountain,
glorious diamond peak upon
peak.
This is the realm of that
mountain of imagination that I
was showing you in the passage
from Good Readers and Good
Writers.
This is Humbert's
meditation on looking at a map
and seeing a range in which
imagination can have pure play.
Now, as it turns out,
if you keep reading there,
he's disappointed to find what
the Appalachian mountains
actually look like in the United
States.
He finds them much less
romantic, a kind of garbage
dump, a very seedy stretch of
the world.
But what I want you to note is
how that chapter break brings us
from Lolita's first efforts at
motivating the romantic
clichés;
her first efforts immediately
pay off in transporting him into
that mountainous imagination.
This is how we know that she's
got him;
she's got him in the
imagination.
She's not just seduced his
lustful body.
She has him fully under her
power at this point,
and it's that chapter break
that you can see demonstrating
the fact.
Now, I want to look at page
231,232.
This is one of those passages
that Nabokov points out as being
special to him.
This is Lolita playing tennis.
So, 231.
"My Lolita"--this is near the
bottom of the page:
…had a way of
raising her bent left knee at
the ample and springy start of
the service cycle,
when there would develop and
hang in the sun for a second a
vital web of balance between
toed foot,
pristine armpit,
burnished arm,
and far back-flung racket as
she smiled up with gleaming
teeth at the small globe
suspended so high in the zenith
of the powerful and graceful
cosmos she had created for the
express purpose of falling upon
it with a clean,
resounding crack of her golden
whip.
It had that serve of hers
beauty, directness,
youth, a classical purity of
trajectory and was,
despite its spanking pace,
fairly easy to return,
having as it did no twist or
sting to its long,
elegant hop."
And then a little further down
the page: "She who was so cruel
and crafty in everyday life
revealed an innocence of
frankness,
a kindness of ball playing that
permitted a second-rate but
determined player,
no matter how uncouth and
incompetent, to poke and cut his
way to victory."
That pose--the pose of tennis
service, the raised foot--it's
the same pose she uses to seduce
him in that scene I just read
after their fight:
"I feel sort of romantic
tonight."
She is acting out a form:
in the first case the form of
romantic fiction,
the heroine who swoons back;
in this scene the form of the
game, the perfect form of
tennis.
And he says she did a perfect
imitation of top-notch tennis.
This is on 231:
"Her form was indeed an
absolutely perfect imitation of
absolutely top-notch tennis,
without any utilitarian
results."
It's perfect tennis,
but she never wins.
And he reflects on 232:
"Had not something within her
been broken by me,
not that I realized it then,
she would have had on top of
her perfect form the will to win
and would have become a real
girl champion."
He reads the non-utilitarian
quality of her form as the
evidence of her broken nature.
But I would like to suggest
that it's precisely that
non-utilitarian quality that is
the mark of her wholeness in a
certain way.
If aesthetic bliss is what
Nabokov confesses is his
ultimate aim for art in the
essay On a Book Entitled
Lolita,
something like that is what
Lolita gives us in her perfect
tennis form without the will to
win: the frankness,
beauty, kindness,
lack of deception.
And, in that sense,
it is also a version of play,
of children's play--not
competitive play,
which is a different kind of
thing--but pure play.
And this gets us back again to
that image of the chess problem
that I was talking about in my
first lecture.
The chess problem is not in the
middle of a game.
It's a puzzle,
but it has for its delight a
kind of solitary quality,
both of the composer and of the
solver of the chess problem.
So, it's not in the course of
competitive play,
and--although he uses the
language of competition to
describe the relationship
between the composer and the
solver--it's not in that sense a
competitive game,
as chess would be:
white against black.
This kind of self-absorbed,
autonomous play of Lolita's
tennis form is the kind of play
that children have.
It doesn't have a point.
It's all process and form.
If the threat to the work
of art, to the novel,
is something like convention,
I want to think hard about what
the threat to this kind of play
is in the novel.
And I want to suggest that the
threat to this kind of play is
parallel to the threat to
children.
The threat to children in the
novel multiplies.
It is not just Lolita who is
threatened, but all sorts of
children.
So, let's begin with
another of those scenes on 213
that Nabokov points out to us,
the Kasbeam barber.
Why did it take him a month to
come up with the Kasbeam barber?
What's going on in this tiny
snippet that's so important?
So here it is.
In Kasbeam,
a very old barber gave me a
very mediocre haircut.
He babbled of a
baseball-playing son of his,
and at every explodent spat
into my neck,
and every now and then wiped
his glasses on my sheet wrap,
or interrupted his tremulous
scissor work to produce faded
newspaper clippings.
And so inattentive was I,
that it came as a shock to
realize, as he pointed to an
easeled photograph among the
ancient gray lotions,
that the mustached young
ballplayer had been dead for the
last thirty years.
So, the barber is speaking
about his son in such a way that
he seems alive,
but, in fact,
he's dead.
So here is one dead child
playing baseball,
or the memory of him playing
baseball is alive with his
father.
If you look down at the very
bottom of that page,
you see "a young woman far gone
in the family way had seated a
rapt baby on a swing and was
rocking it gently,
while a jealous boy of two or
three was making a nuisance of
himself by trying to push or
pull"--there is that word play
again coming back to us--"the
swing board.
He finally succeeded in getting
himself knocked down by it and
bawled loudly as he lay supine
on the grass while his mother
continued to smile gently at
neither of her present
children."
And, if you skip over to 215,
this image comes back of this
mother: "All cars had
disappeared except his station
wagon.
His pregnant young wife was now
getting into it with her baby
and the other more or less
canceled child."
So, here are at least three
examples of canceled children,
and you can use that phrase,
I think, to characterize
Lolita.
She is a canceled child.
Her childhood is stolen from
her by Humbert.
In this scene,
it is the mother's imaginative
preoccupation,
in a sense, that cancels her
children,
and you can ask whether she is
preoccupied with the idea of the
new child within her.
You get that sense of pregnancy
being an inner meaning or an
inner significance,
and perhaps it's a figure for
what preoccupies her,
for the world of imagination
and possibility.
But she has that kind of
distant internal smile.
This is the same kind of smile
that Lolita is said to have--the
beautiful passage where Humbert
remembers Lolita's famous smile
that ranges around the room but
doesn't seem to engage anyone.
It's as if her smile is the
response to an internal imagined
life, one that's inaccessible to
Humbert.
He says of her he does not know
what regions there were in her
mind, what "dim,
adorable regions" there were in
her mind, that he would never
know, that he was denied access
to,
as he raped her.
And so, children--which
have this potential to play--are
consistently canceled,
over and over again.
There are other examples.
On 223 we find out that Mona,
Lolita's friend from the play,
her baby sibling--we're not
told whether it's a boy or
girl--dies,
and we see it in one of those
parentheticals,
223.
This is Mona's letter.
"Now that everything is over,
school, play,
the Roy mess,
mother's confinement (our baby,
alas, did not live),
it all seems a long time ago,
though practically I still bear
traces of the paint."
Again, that parenthetical
elides the death of the child.
We're reminded in this scene of
the death of Lolita's little
brother.
Remember, Charlotte Haze speaks
in her letter of a lost son who
died at the age of two.
The bodies of children pile up,
but other things happen to
children too.
Remember when Lolita and
Humbert are partially discovered
having sex in a field by a
mother and her children
gathering flowers.
They're described as carved,
bluestone children.
And think about the name of
that town, Elphinstone,
of which Nabokov again is
proud: Elphinstone,
a little child of stone,
a small figure of stone.
And the elf-like image is
something that he applies to
Lolita over and over.
So, what you see is
children dead,
children turned to stone,
and this is the dark side of
that fairy tale quality that we
see in other parts of the novel
that's been coming back in our
lectures.
These are children turned to
stone.
And it suggests,
if you go back now to that
scene on 207-208,
as they set out for the second
trip in the middle of the page
(actually a little above):
" I was toying with the idea of
gently trickling across the
Mexican border.
I was braver now than last
year, and there deciding what to
do with my little concubine who
was now 60 inches tall and
weighed 90 pounds."
The threat against Lolita is
growing with her body;
as she gets bigger,
so he becomes murderous towards
her.
And this is allied with his
desire, in a sense,
to crystalize what he has taken
from her.
And here in the middle of the
page a little ways down:
My love's striped
black-and-white cotton frock,
jaunty blue cap,
white socks and brown moccasins
were not quite in keeping with
the large,
beautifully cut aquamarine on a
silver chainlet which gemmed her
throat, a spring rain gift from
me.
He has taken summer rain that
the page before,
we are told,
gemmed her hair ("shook her
gemmed hair,
stretched towards me two bare
arms, raised one knee")--"her
gemmed hair"--takes that rain,
and ossifies it,
makes it lapidary,
turns it to stone in the
aquamarine, and puts it on a
chainlet.
And the diminutive "let" at the
end of the chain doesn't really
cover up the chain itself.
It doesn't really mitigate
against the confinement he has
perpetrated on Lolita.
She is in chains,
and just because it's
ornamented, just because it has
the diminutive,
doesn't mean that it's not a
chain.
It's around her throat,
that vulnerable place.
So, if art as play is
something like performance,
something like an embodied art,
the art of the tennis service,
or even the art of theater or
film, there is another kind of
art that is gemlike,
hard, cold, equally formal but
dead: "bluestone children."
So, this is the other form that
the aesthetic can take.
And I think that Nabokov is
consistently concerned about
these two valences of what the
aesthetic can look like.
So, if it can look like the
gem, it can last forever.
As Humbert dreams at the very
end of the novel,
he says, "I am thinking of
aurochs and angels,
the secret of durable pigments,
prophetic sonnets,
the refuge of art,
as this is the only immortality
you and I may share,
my Lolita."
He thinks of his account as
that kind of enduring stone-like
object, and it may give
immortality, but it traps her
there in immortality with him.
He is then as immortal as she
is in the pages of this screed.
And so--like the chainlet--it
takes that stone-like
distillation of life,
turning rain to stone,
turning life to the
representation by your
tormentor.
It turns into something durable
that will outlast them.
So, the problem with art is in
a sense that it is immortal.
That's the problem.
If life is threatened over and
over again in this novel by
mortality--dead children,
Lolita growing up inevitably,
painfully, putting her at risk.
Her body grows;
she can't do anything about
it--that's mortality,
the passage of time.
This difference--between
the art that's lapidary and the
art that's living--is that the
art that's living,
by very virtue of being alive,
can also die.
So, this is the problem with
the autonomous work of art.
If your dream as a writer is to
make an autonomous work of art
that has, as we say in a very
colloquial way,
a life of its own,
but the problem is that there
is something about life that's
dependent on the possibility of
its negation.
That's why on Valentine's Day
you might give your lover real
flowers rather than plastic
ones.
It's the very potential to
decay that makes them beautiful.
And so, the problem here is
that Nabokov dreams of an art
that's living,
something like the butterflies
that he was so enchanted with in
his life and work outside of
fiction.
And the butterfly does appear
in just one moment,
and it's during the tennis
scene.
As Humbert and Lolita play,
there is one butterfly that
flits between them.
It's a mark of their equality
as artists in that moment.
The butterfly is the perfect
work of art because it is both a
representation and alive.
It has eyes on its wings.
It looks like a leaf.
It is nature in its aesthetic
form as imitation of itself,
life as an imitation of life.
Can you make a novel,
as he says in the essay,
that will "sprout wings and
grow claws" in secret in his
mind?
That's an image taken from the
metamorphosis of the butterfly
within the chrysalis.
He wants his novel to be
like that living butterfly,
but the threat is always that
it will be more like the
aquamarine.
And I want to suggest to you
that the aquamarine has an even
darker personal significance to
him.
When his family fled Russia,
the only things of value that
they brought with them were some
of his mother's jewels.
These jewels were hidden in a
canister of talcum powder,
later buried in the yard under
a tree in Europe as they moved
from place to place in their
exile,
and they were gradually sold
off one by one to fund their
life.
Those jewels,
I would suggest to you,
carried with them the sense
that they were the ossified
remains of a radiant Russian
life,
and so the image of the jewel
is a kind of dead childhood,
even for him as a writer.
So, where is Nabokov in here?
I think that's one of the
places where Nabokov is.
It's Nabokov meditating on this
problem.
I want to read that last
passage on 308 that he mentions
in the essay.
Actually, it starts on 307.
This is Humbert standing on the
lip of a ravine by the side of
the road, listening to the
sounds of a small town rising up
to him:
And soon I realized that
all of these sounds were of one
nature, that no other sounds but
these came from the streets of
the transparent town,
with the women at home and the
men away.
Reader, what I heard was but
the melody of children at play,
nothing but that,
and so limpid was the air that
within this vapor of blended
voices majestic and minute,
remote and magically near,
frank and divinely enigmatic,
one could hear now and then,
as if released,
an almost inarticulate spurt of
vivid laughter or the crack of a
bat or the clatter of a toy
wagon,
but it was all really too far
for the eye to distinguish any
movement in the lightly etched
streets.
I stood listening to that
musical vibration from my lofty
slope, to those flashes of
separate cries with a kind of
demure murmur for background,
and then I knew that the
hopelessly poignant thing was
not Lolita's absence from my
side,
but the absence of her voice
from that concord.
This then is my story.
I have reread it.
It has bits of marrow sticking
to it.
And blood.
And beautiful,
bright-green flies.
The living voice is missing.
What you get instead is the
corpse of the novel,
with marrow,
and blood, and flies.
Dolly Schiller--aptly named of
course for the German Romantic
philosopher who advocated play
as a mode of the aesthetic,
German Romanticist of the
nineteenth century--Dolly takes
on that identity as the Romantic
figure,
and she dies giving birth to a
girl, to a baby girl;
she dies in childbed.
Remember I asked you from
the preface, John Ray's preface,
to figure out who Dolly
Schiller is, who dies in
childbed.
Well, by now you should know
that's Lolita.
So she dies giving birth to a
child.
She has taken on the mantle of
Romantic artist,
but she dies giving birth to a
live person: two modes of
creativity embodied in Lolita,
in that one act,
and in that name.
She is giving birth to a real,
live thing--not a creation that
is more like stone,
but an actual person.
And so, what you see is not
just the paradox of wanting your
work of art to be a living work
of art,
to be personified in that way
or made animate that then
exposes it to mortality--the
Woolworth's workers who don't
read it and who think no one in
the world ever reads it,
that kind of risk.
Your book cannot live if it has
no reader to meet it at the top
of that mountain.
But Dolly embodies that other
kind of creativeness:
human creativity of the literal
kind, giving birth to a child.
I think it's telling that this
kind of creation is a failure;
it cannot succeed in the
confines of this novel.
Nabokov had a way of making an
absence at a point of his utmost
investment.
For instance,
in his autobiography he notes
the date of and the phone call
that tells his mother that his
father has been assassinated.
But he doesn't tell you until
many pages later what it was
that happened on that date.
He says, "On" whatever the date
was;
I think it was March 22^(nd)
"when my mother received a phone
call…."
And then, it just goes on about
something else,
doesn't tell you what that
phone call was.
It was his father's
assassination.
Like those absences in other
parts of his writing,
I think this absence,
this failure of any birth,
it marks a sort of vanishing
point of art,
that art somehow can't quite
compete with the real
inventiveness of nature and of
human persons.
He's going to try.
He's going to try to give us a
living prose,
but this is the end against
which it finds itself pressed.
Next time, we're turning to a
very different kind of writing,
a writing equally preoccupied
with its relationship to the
world,
to life, but very differently
approaching that problem.
So, try to think about that as
you turn to On the Road.